- [Narrator] We are the
paradoxical ape bipedal naked,
large-brained,
long the master of fire
tools and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
we grow up slowly we hand down knowledge.
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines.
to exchange insights
on who we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible by the
generosity of humans like you you.
- Well you all remembered
to come here today,
and you all remembered how to get here,
and you all have plans for what you're
going to do after this meeting is over
later today because that's what it's
all about our world is the world of
memories and we are our memories.
That we think about memory
often about the past
but memory is really about the future
because it enables us to use information
that you gained in order to get along in
life and that's what it's all about.
Well I'm going to talk
about some people for
whom the future is not terribly
important but the past is
awfully important.
Unusual people indeed
there is the question of
the very famous psychologist
maybe the founder of modern
psychology William James instead of some
experiences no memory survives the
instance of their passage of others.
It is confined to a few moments hours or
days others may be recalled as long as
life endures can we explain these
differences?
Why is it that that you can
remember right now exactly what I said
even with the intonation you could mimic
me and tomorrow you're going to remember
that there was a meeting that you came
to and you're gonna remember a few
elements well I'm gonna do it's not like
that for all people.
There was a man named Daniel
McCartney about whom an
article was published in the Journal of
speculative philosophy.
Dobby probably subscribed to that journal.
Journal of speculative philosophy
which I had never heard of
until somebody drew my attention to this,
who was tested in 1870 by a
man who discovered that this
individual claimed that he
had a very strong memory
of his personal experiences.
So when he was 54 years
old in 1870 he was asked a
lot of questions about his life going
back many many years back actually to
the age of 4 years old and he responded
in every case to the questions in two or
three seconds maybe the test was
repeated several days later and he
responded with the same answers but not
using the same words that is he knew
what it would he could remember but he'd
use different words to say it.
So what happened on October 8th 1828.
Wednesday was cloudy
and drizzling and rain I
carried dinner to my father where he was
getting out coal.
I was 42 years ago let
4:13me run down let's
take April 4th 1841 he
4:18answered in 3 seconds
it was a Sunday it
4:20was rainy and muddy general Harrison
4:22died that day.
February 2nd 1856 two second response.
Saturday was most awful cold it
was a coldest day ever see in my life
records for Iowa February 4th indicated
the coldest day in 1856 now that's the
the bottom that's my interrogation
because all of these are claims that
people make and you could make them up
you know what did you do in June 12 1993
and you go oh I went shopping that day I
had a fight with my boyfriend or
whatever I wouldn't know whether that's
true or not so to my the limited ability
that I had I looked up the records for
things that he said when he said it
snowed it rained
on the day that he said it was a heavy
snow that was a heaviest day of snowing
in Iowa that year on the day that it
rained it was within two days of the
date that he gave so to the extent that
we can validate these claims they
appeared to be accurate he appears to
have a phenomenal memory of his personal
experiences but not a lot is known about
him I'm just reporting what was reported
and that rather obscure journal now I
didn't know anything about him I had
never read that article as a matter of
fact our article was sent to me by a
wag who after we started
publishing out work on highy
superior autobiographical
memory said essentially
he said yeah yeah yeah you didn't know
about this for now and he sent me the
article from this journal that I do not
subscribe to and I haven't I
haven't found it on PubMed.
So in 2000 a young woman a
32 year old named Jill price,
sent me an email and said she had a
memory problem and would like to meet me.
Well I wrote back to her and said this
is a Research Institute not a clinic but
I can direct you to it.
Well would you think when
somebody said I have a memory
problem all right.
Well she said oh no no that's not sir my
memory problem is that I don't forget.
So I decided to meet with her I,
I really thought that it
wasn't that she probably
didn't I really did think this was a
very strange behavior but I agreed to
meet with her and I
when she came since
we have never seen anybody
like they were tested.
I didn't know what to do.
So I had been given for Christmas this is
2000 and I had been given a coffee table
book which is about this thick which is
newspaper reports for every day in the
last century.
You may have seen them they
were around in that time.
And so all I did was open that
book and ask her questions.
I turned to a page and which
was after the age of 13 because
she said that's when
she began to have this
ability and I question her
and these are the kinds of
things that I asked.
I ask about an event.
I said when was there a
major San Diego plane crash?
How many of you remember
the plane crash in
September 25th 1978?
How many of you would have
remembered the date if I
hadn't said that?
All right when did the
person Gulf War start?
Wednesday January 16 891 and so on down
the line.
The one at the bottom I want to
draw your attention to I asked her when
was the Iranian invasion of the U.S.
embassy and she said November 4th in 1979
and I was looking at the
article right in front of me,
and I said well you have it
pretty close you're several days
off and she said no no no that this is
the date and this was written here right
in the book and she said
well the book is wrong.
Well it turns out that I was
looking at the date of the
article that was written
and down in the body of the
article was the true the valid time
which is November 4th 1979.
But it was her assurance
that was important that
the book was wrong.
She said now we also.
I also asked her about dates.
I gave her a date and
she had to tell me what
happened on that date.
So August 16 1977 Elvis died,
Let's go down November
4th 1979 and Ray that's
right the Iranian invasion
of any US embassy.
October 5th 1983 bombing
in Beirut Northridge
earthquake and Lockerbie plane crash and
so these are all accurate.
These are her responses and I'm looking
at the book so I knew the the answers
but I knew them because
I was looking at them.
Now we we can't take these
statements as valid as a
matter of fact she says that she remembers
being in a crib when she was an infant.
Well I'm not going to
accept that we have no
way of validating and besides that,
plenty of people see videos
of themselves and cribs or
pictures of themselves and so that's not
going to do the job.
We have to validate it.
So fortunately in her case she kept a
diary for many years of her life and
whoever she made a claim we were able to
untie a little pink ribbon it was tied
around this little book that she had and
lots of books a stack like that open it
up and see of what she said about it
was accurate at one time we asked her to
give us the the dates
of the last 20 Easters.
How many of you remember the date
of the last Easter as she told us the
the date of the last 20 Easter's.
She also told us without
asking what she did
on each of those dates and we could
check that out because we're able to
peek into her Diaries and validate some
of that information.
Now I'm going to show you
some other subjects let me I
have to say that we we got a little
publicity inadvertently sort of we went
on NPR disguised her name had but talked
about this a little bit
and then a little bit
of newspaper of publicity.
So we began to get subjects and
by the time 2010 rolled around
we had five subjects.
Now they were filmed by 60
Minutes on December 19 2010
That was a Sunday.
It's help it's helpful that 60 minutes is
always on a Sunday that's best to look
look I did I did well go on
I don't I don't want to show
off anymore so I'm going to show you a
clips from TV programs in which we had
this the first one is Louise Owen who is
a professional violinist in New York a
very high level violinist appears
frequently both in groups and also solos
and and it's a really very charming
person so I'll show you her first.
- [Announcer] McGaugh
says this type of memory,
is completely new to science.
so he and his colleagues
have had to devise,
their own tests like this
one on public events.
- [Woman] October 19 1987 it's a Monday,
that was the day the
big stock market crash,
and the cellist Jacqueline
Duprey died that day.
- The Berlin Wall falls on what day?
- November 9th 1989 which was a Thursday,
- Christopher Reeves accident
occurred on what day?
- It was Saturday May 27th 1995,
- And when were the Oscars held in 1999
in 1999, Sunday March 21st.
- yes perfect.
- Note that she didn't
say give me a moment.
I'll think about it.
She describes it as a google search and
when she talks about it
she uses expressions.
She says it's just there it just
comes up like that and you can see.
The ease with which she did
it the smile on her face
and the speed of response.
Responding within a second
or two it's right there.
Let's move back in time now to 1990.
It rained on several days
in January and February.
Can you name the dates on which it rained.
- [Announcer] Believe it or not she could.
- Let's see it was slightly
rainy and cloudy on January 14,
15th it was very hot.
The weekend of the 27th or 28th no rain.
- [Announcer] We checked the
official weather records,
- It rained very hard
on Sunday February 4th
- [Announcer] and she was right
- All right that was 20 years ago.
From the time that I
asked her I was asking her
when did it rain in New
York City 20 years ago.
In January February and
she nailed every day.
Now this is important
because for many of the other
examples that I've shown
people could memorize,
that is if you set your mind to it,
you could memorize thing and
you spend all of your time
memorizing experiences
like learning a list of
words or whatever.
I suppose I chose this example
because it's highly unlikely
unless you want to challenge
me on this that she sat around
for 20 years saying I must
remember the days in which it
rained in New York on those two months.
Now we have also by luck found
several children who have
this ability and this is
important also because of the
possible interpretation that
these people have the ability
because they spend a lot of time,
rehearsing rehearsing rehearsing.
Children don't have much time to do that.
So I'm going to show you a
couple of fairly young children
who have ability which is
just as good as our adults.
- [Announcer] Osler age 10.
what day of the week was Halloween 2011?
- Monday that one I didn't
even have to think about.
- New Year's Day 2010
- Friday.
I remember that 'cause I was
up all night and balloons came.
- [Announcer] That's when Jake was 6.
He lives in st.Louis, loves sports
and he is in most respects
a typical ten year old.
- What happened related to
school on January 30th 2013.
- That day I'm pretty sure
that's a trick question.
Yeah we didn't have school that day.
You know we had a
lightning storm last night.
Yeah we didn't have school that day.
- [Man] 7th 2012 do you know
what day of the week that was?
- That was a Sunday.
- [Man] you're right.
- [Announcer] There is
exactly one child in the world
other than Jake who's been identified so
far with this ability.
11 year old Tyler Hickenbottom,
and in a fortuitous coincidence,
Tyler happens to be an identical
twin he and his brother
Chad share the same genes.
- I think I might have
worn an orange shirt.
- [Announcer] But surprisingly
not the same memory.
- Life can be tough.
This is very interesting we
are doing genetic studies
now are collaborating in genetic studies.
And the first thing we want to find out is
are they really identical twins.
The parents claim that they are and we're
going to re-check that.
Once again the reason for
the interest in children is
because we want to find out
the the age at which this is
first recognized by children.
We have younger children now who are 10
years old who have the ability going
back to the age of five and a little bit
earlier than that.
So this is not a an ability
which is acquired later in life
it appears fairly early on how early we
don't yet know.
Now here is a distribution
of the the ability of
people who have what we call h sam or
highly superior autobiographical memory
and on the right in a white and blue you
see the distribution of the percent
correct on a 30 question quiz
of the kind that i've
already talked about.
Ranging from let's say 35 percent correct,
up to 75 percent correct.
On the left in orange
you see controls age and
sex match controls and you can see that
this is not this ability is not the end
of an arc extreme end of a normal
distribution it is a different
distribution also you can see some white
on the left mixed for the orange these
are people who claim that they had the
ability and were just like controls if
you look on the far left there are four
people who claim they have the ability
and they aren't worse than controls.
we gave the best of those a tendex quiz,
asking for 10 dates that we
selected the day of the week a
verifiable event that
happened on that day,
an autobiographical event
which we did not check,
but they claimed it was autobiographical.
And what you can see
is in the blue are the
people that have this ability and the
orange are us and you can see that they
get about 14 percent correct on day of
the week which is one
out of seven by the way.
They have no verifiable
event and so you see,
they're quite different we also gave them.
an autobiographical memory
test and here they validated.
We asked him the first day at university,
the first day at elementary
school so on down the list
that you can see and we've actually got
all of the data support all of that our
H Sam subjects gave 145 verified details.
Controls gave a total of 24 details
which we did not bother to verify.
All right here are some characteristics.
These folks are highly accurate on
autobiographical remembering.
They are not at all
exceptional and learning and
laboratory tests we've done a lot of
experimental psychology types of tests
with them and they're absolutely on
average normal one thing that is of
interest they also show signs of
compulsiveness and they saw some
differences in brain region so I'll show
you quickly here here's a region to the
uncinate fasciculus which is a fiber
pathway that goes from the temporal lobe
up to the frontal lobes and this is more
obvious in an MRI structural MRI it's
also a region that is found to be
deficient in people who have highly
deficient autobiographical memory the
parahippocampal gyrus which is not too
much of a surprise because that region
has been implicated in memory and also
found in people who would have
strong memory of other kinds
and the Lentiform nucleus
which is in the region of
the caudate nucleus which has a some
studies have shown to be significant
significantly observed in people who
have obsessive-compulsive disorder and
all of our people score highly on
obsessive-compulsive tests and they also
display an obsessiveness germ avoidance
and other things I have a time
I could tell you some very
interesting things about what
they avoid so here are
some important questions.
First what insights can
we learn about memory,
is it strong storage of information or
is it exceptional retrieval we don't
think is simply exceptional
retrieval because
it's exceptional retrieval
of their own autobiographical
experiences not of other things.
We even did an experiment
in which we gave them
some information and then they had a
discussion with the experimenter and
they were tested later on they
remembered everything that they said and
nothing that the experimenter said so it
it is all about them.
Is their involvement of
a rote emotional arousal
well that's what I do for a living
that's my main research and yet we have
plenty of examples of them remembering
pretty banal things you saw that list
that I showed you my favorite example is
our first subject I asked him if asked her
if she knew who Bing Crosby was and
she said yes she would
have been very young
maybe in her teenage years I said
you know what happened to him and she
said oh yes he died on the Golf Course
in Spain and she gave me the date and
the day and I said how did you know that
she said well my mother was driving me
to a soccer game and the news came on
over the radio and she
remembers that to this day.
Is there a genetic basis we are
studying that at the
present time we don't know
Neuro biological implications I think
this is the most important one and this
has been touched on
already in the symposium.
These these individuals not
only can give us clues to
understanding how their
brain works in order to produce
this this really phenomenal
memory ability but by understanding the
neural underpinnings of this we can get
a greater understanding of how the brain
processes memory new insights can come
from from this ultimately.
And finally why is this
ability so rarer if memory
is so important I started off by saying
as our most important ability
why is it that we are so poor
in what do and in a certain
way they are better?
William James said forgetting
is as important the function
as recollecting if we remembered
everything we should be
on most occasions as ill off
as if we remembered nothing.
These people remember an awful
lot about in a way nothing.
Just trivial events they remember it quite
well they are unremarkable
in other respects
if they were here in the room and there
may be several people people here.
If you didn't ask memory
questions you would not be able to
identify them.
They remember for a long
period of time and we
need to find out and our research
will continue to do that.
Thank you